in a small cluster of trees each branch  a trapeze the slowest Acrobat show ten  steel foxes in a row  does it bring you unease that these  bearers of disease are more useful than  beads at the giving us flowers  panting they sleep through daylight  hours a rhythmic beat works against the  heat Commonwealth parks very heartbeat  in sync they dance around a skating rink  kissing it in an indelible drink because  the first one flew the lust group to  disappear into a golden hue the others  said after you the Sun began to set the  time was right to run from threat at  lights last hour they relocate to  Telstra Tower  a single bat leads the sky he's the  bravest guy the rest follow suit in  pursuit of nectar and fruit an orange  color on a gray suit 1000 bats fly on  route their blackness against the  moonlight the darkest starlight they  twinkle to their campsite and will  return at first light  [Music]